so maybe we can just uh discuss the
Leaning the current leaning of Academia
towards the left which you describe in
various different perspectives so one
there's a voter registration ratio chart
that you have by Department which I
think is interesting can you explain
this chart and can you explain what it
shows yeah when I started fire in 2001 I
didn't take the Viewpoint diversity
issue as seriously I thought it was just
something that right Wingers complained
about
but I really started to get what happens
when you have a community with low
um with low uh Viewpoint diversity and
actually a lot of the research that I
got most interested in was uh done in
conjunction with the great cast sunstein
who writes a lot about group
polarization
um because as and the research on this
is very strong that essentially when you
have groups with um
political diversity and you can see this
actually in judges for example it tends
to produce you know reliably more
moderate you know outcomes whereas
groups that are that have low political
diversity tend to sort of spiral Spiral
off in their own Direction and when you
have a super majority of people from
just one political perspective that's a
problem for the production of ideas it
creates a situation where there are
sacred ideas
um and when you look at some of the
Departments
um you know I think the ask the estimate
from the Crimson is that Harvard is has
three percent conservatives but when you
look at different departments there are
Elite departments that have literally no
um uh conservatives uh in them and I
think that's that's on a healthy
intellectual uh environment the problem
is definitely worse
um as you get more Elite uh we
definitely see more cases of uh Lefty
professors getting canceled at less
Elite schools it it gets worse as you as
you get down from the the elite schools
that's where a lot of the one-third of
attempts to get uh professors punished
that are successful you know do do come
from the right and largely from off
campus uh off-campus sources and we
spend a lot of time talking about that
in in the book as well
um that's something that I do think is
underappreciated uh but when it comes to
the low Viewpoint diversity it's you
know it works out kind of like you'd
expect to a degree you know economics is
what four to one or something like that
it's not as bad but then when you start
getting into some of the humanities you
know like there are departments that
they're literally none
is there a good why
to why did the universities University
faculty Administration move to the left
yeah
I don't love and this is an argument
that you'll sometimes run into on the
left uh just the argument that well
people on the left are just smarter
right and it's like okay it's
interesting because at least the
research as of
10 years ago was indicating that if you
dig a little bit deeper into that a lot
of the people who do consider themselves
on the left tend to be a little bit more
libertarian this is something that
Pinker you know wrote a fair amount
about the idea that we're just smarter
it it it is not an opinion I I'm at
least bit comfortable with
um I do think that that uh it that
departments take on
um momentum when they become a place
where you're like wow it'd be really
unpleasant for me to work in this
department if I'm the token conservative
and I think that takes on a life of its
own there are also departments where a
lot of the ideologies kind of explicitly
leftist
um you look at education schools a lot
of the a lot of the stuff that is
actually left over from what is
correctly called critical race theories
it is present and you end up having that
in in a number of the Departments
um and it would be very strange to be a
in many departments a you know a
conservative social worker Professor I'm
sure they exist but
it there's a lot of pressure to
shut up if you are